which of europe is also slowly reopening
thousands descended on beaches in greece
over the weekend while in italy more
shops and restaurants are again
welcoming customers chris Livesay
reports now from rome on what's being
called a calculated risk it's been 70
days and 70 nights but today churches in
Italy can reopen to the general public
and so can st. Peter's where Pope
Francis celebrated Mass but not before
being sanitized inside and out and in
some cases with the help of the military
like the Church of Saints Peter and Paul
in Rome priests must wear masks and
gloves to give communion parishioners
receive it with their hands not directly
in their mouths
of course even with added safety
measures there's still a risk walking
together creates more opportunities for
the disease to spread in a country where
people are still getting sick and dying
every day is now really a good time to
reopen the country I mean the number
decreasing every every day I mean more
people that are coming out from this
disease including Pier Paolo Soleri is
both the deputy health minister and a
coronavirus survivor
now that Italians are recovering from
the disease faster than their
contracting it he says Italy should
leave its sick bed it's like you're
discharging the country yeah and today
not only churches but also hairdressers
museums and shops can reopen so by one
sobering estimate 30 percent can't
afford to many bankrupted by the
pandemic in nearby Germany the
Bundesliga this weekend became Europe's
first top-tier soccer league to retake
the field albeit without fans in the
seats
as mass protests against social
restrictions raged across the country
Greece reopened the famed Acropolis to
the public as they soften their lockdown
today as well while Spain had its lowest
daily death toll since mid-march and
tomorrow even Russia will ease some
measures this despite a continued rise
in infections and deaths there but hopes
are high in Britain the government says
the University of Oxford is progressing
well in its race for a vaccine and has
reached a deal to make 30 million doses
available to the UK by September if
trials are successful now here at the
Vatican st. Peter's may be reopen but
you'll probably only see Italians around
for now due to international travel bans
Italy wants to reopen its borders on
June 3rd but starting first only with
other European Union countries just in
time for summer vacations Gael all right
there is such a thing as summer vacation
I hear thank you crib